he's been dabbling in Adolf Hitler his
whole life uh keeps Hitler speeches at a
bedside they want to keep these people
in a complete state of panic and then
you wonder why people are freaking out
why are people wandering around why is
everybody on prescription drugs why is
everybody constantly uh suffering from
anxiety and all the rest of it it's
because they're telling you that he's
Hitler he's going to use this book to
shut off the Internet it's a lot of
stuff that he's doing constantly
constantly constantly oh and Hitler
stuff here we go hours Douglas after
making these remarks the former
president um doubled down and wrote a
post saying this illegal immigration is
poisoning the blood of our nation as I
mentioned President Biden and the White
House are comparing this to the words of
Adolf Hitler and specifically the words
that were written in mine comp and I
want to read for folks the comparison
that we see within mine comp so they
understand the gravity of this situation
the poison which has invaded the
national body especially the strong
influx of foreign blood that is from
mine comp as a historian Doug what did
you hear in the former president's
remarks I heard a former president who
is um Jing on fascism there's no
question about that being aign from mine
comp he knows it uh he's been dabbling
in Adolf Hitler his whole life uh keeps
Hitler speeches at a bedside uh uh minec
seems to be the book that's inspired
Trump the most so it's heinous because
it's it's a kind of language meant to
belittle people dehumanize them uh and
when we're not making a an anti-trump
comment when we're saying he is a
fascist guys that really we're dealing
with a fight in our country between
democracy and Fascism and Trump's
telling you that he's not he doesn't
really mind the Hitler comparison
because at heart he admires Hitler at
heart he admires Hitler his daughter and
several of his grandchildren are Jewish
do you know that Hitler not a fan of the
Jews uh as a general rule uh also that
guy there that historian he's this was
his exact line he keeps Hitler speeches
at his bed how would he know that Doug
Doug have you been sleeping with Don
what are you talking about like really
think about it you think Donald Trump
Donald Trump sleeps with Hitler speeches
at his bed like what do you think he has
he has the tanning cream on the side of
the bed obviously well think about it
Trump wakes up try to picture Trump
waking up right he wakes up little
orange stuff some hairspray what else
like what else would he have he puts on
the red tie I feel like he puts the red
tie on before he even gets like it's
just madeup dribble they just brought on
a historian to claim that he knows what
Donald Trump has on his bed side
completely
insane